hey youtubers is Charlie so the big news
is the tom felton from Harry Potter is
going to be on the flash season 3 as a
regular something of an antagonist to
bear so I'm just gonna explain what's
going on I have a few ideas about who he
might be playing the casting
announcement that everyone was spreading
around named him as Julian Dorn but I
think that's a big misdirect that's not
a name from the comics it seems like
he's playing air quotes in original
character and while that might be the
case it just feels like the flash
wouldn't do that like they're so
comic-book II that of course I'm just
expecting this to be some random name
that they used to cast the actor and
then we'll learn about the mysterious
secrets that he's keeping he's basically
his character is gonna be working with
Barry inside the Central City Police
Department there are a number of
characters in the flash comics that have
started out working with Barry inside
the police department that have later
become villains but just because his
character sounds like he's going to be a
villain doesn't mean he'll end up being
the main villain I just feel like he's
gonna be another Captain Cold type
character someone who's not quite a
villain not quite a hero he's just gonna
be like the bad boy inside the police
department which pretty much guarantees
that Caitlin snow is gonna fall in love
with him she always falls in love with
the bad boys so the minute she gives him
eyes or says something about him that
makes you think like she's interested
you know is on like up okay
he is very clearly the villain this
season so lay all your bets now will
Caitlin fall in love with his character
this season if you really want to get
funny about it you should say all of the
women are gonna fall in love with him on
the show and when you hear the pitch for
his character like someone who is
mistrustful of Barry's good-natured ways
this season flashpoint is gonna be all
about the mistakes that Barry makes
while he's trying to do good things now
you've all probably heard about or read
or watched the flashpoint storyline
think of the flash season three's
version of flashpoint is just being like
the flash collateral damage so I'm
expecting some of Barry's relationships
to suffer as a result of what he's done
with his mother but they'll have some
fun with that it's not gonna completely
change the tone of the TV show it's
still gonna move like the flash moves
it's still gonna have that bouncy funny
feel to it so it will still feel like
the flash that you've been watching for
the last two years it's just that some
of the character dynamics will change
and they'll use it as an opportunity to
create new villains like people that may
not have
been villains in the previous timeline
before Barry changed it so if the
obvious difference is this antagonist
character that they're bringing on and
just to be clear they haven't called him
a villain
they just say he's a character who is
mistrustful of Barry and tries to learn
his secret but he is also hiding a
secret himself so they could go any
number of different directions it just
sounds like if they're gonna do
something different that they haven't
done before in terms of villains given
the types of characters that tom felton
typically plays beyond Harry Potter he's
known to play very edgy characters like
he's leaned into the Draco Malfoy curve
so he doesn't really play characters
that are like Cisco's so that's why I
think his character is gonna be
something of a Captain cold type villain
meaning that he could be a potential
rogue which you know number one
possibility would be dr. alchemy the
second version of the character was
created by Geoff Johns worked inside the
Central City Police Department in the
crime lab with Barry and then eventually
became a row but he didn't start out
that way so if they want him to be a
comic book character and they don't want
to do another speedster that would just
be my top pick but a lot of you are like
what if he's playing Godspeed because in
the comics there's a new villain who's a
speedster called Godspeed who is Barry's
partner inside the police department but
that's a very different story if it
looks like they are going in that
direction though I will totally explain
what's going on with flash rebirth in
that story line but that's happening
right now in the comics and usually the
TV show doesn't do that usually it will
just pull characters names or particular
storylines and just mix and match things
so whoever he does end up being will
probably be a combination of a couple
different characters but let me know in
the comments which character do you
think that he's playing do you think
he's gonna be one of the ropes do you
think he's gonna be dr. alchemy do you
think he's gonna be another speedster I
just I feel like it's too soon for them
to do another speedster just every
single season the main villain is a
speedster that just feels too cheap and
we have Wally West like if they're gonna
do more speedster stuff they would
probably focus on Wally West and Jesse
quick because Jesse quick is coming back
as a series regular in addition to Tom
Cavanagh they didn't really explain who
Tom Cavanagh is gonna play he could be
another version of Harrison wells he
could be a completely different
character I think he'll be a version of
Harrison wells but it just remains to be
seen the probably teased more when they
dropped the Comic Con trailer and that
will be like the first trailer for the
season but just as a tea
there was this funny thing that iris
West just said her Candice Patton said
who plays iris West she said she really
wanted to play a villain if she could at
some point I don't necessarily think
that's a teaser for season three because
I think they've recorded this before
season two is over but they've only just
posted it now so I'll play it right here
real quick I know if you could be a
superhero or a villain which one would
you be in real life
I would definitely want to be a
superhero because but on TV and in the
movies
I would definitely wanna be a bad guy oh
good to be bad I don't know I think it's
fun yeah I think play a bad badass
no-good badass yeah I played good you
know yeah so you can see it's them just
having a little bit of fun and most of
the actors are on vacation meaning that
they recorded this a long time ago and
they're just posting it now so yes I am
expecting iris West to be different when
Barry goes back to the future but I
don't know that she's gonna be a villain
although that is a really exciting
thought it would put Barry more in a
position like Cisco who is just weak in
the knees for gold and glider and the
interesting thing about gold and gliders
character is is that she just got cast
on another CW show so it might be easier
for her to crossover with the flash so
we might see golden glider come back but
giveaway time congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Jared Hashimoto
you win a $20 Amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
details so I'll leave you guys with this
it's just the biggest rumor that I've
heard is that the main villain will not
be a speedster so I think that's why tom
Felton is one of the top picks it just
feels like such a big casting for them
to get that they would give him one of
the biggest roles of the season which
usually ends up being the villain so
what I'm expecting is for the next
couple of weeks as we get closer to
comic-con they'll just continue to
announce new characters that they're
bringing onto the show so whatever ends
up happening I'll totally do videos for
it so be sure to subscribe to get
everything so while you guys wait for me
to post my next video you can click here
for my review and Easter eggs from the
Batman V
Ultimate Edition cut and you can click
here for my Game of Thrones Season seven
predictions thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight